are you fine
we can take
[Music]
please free the passage between
the two aunts please
the chairman of the landing committee
the mayor of Ver-sur-Mer
and the master of ceremonies will
now welcome the
civil and military authorities
then follow the honors to the flag and
the review of the holes
[Music]
[Music] [
Music]
rest
at the raising of the colors [
Music]
watch out for the colors
send
[Music]
rest
to present your weapon
watch out for the colors
send
[Music]
[Applause]
rest
present weapon
attention for colors
send
[Music]
rest
attention for colors
send
[Music] [
Applause]
rest
attention for colors
send [
Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
present weapon
attention for colors
send
[Music]
rest
watch out for the colors
[Music]
now
watch out for the colors really
send
[Music]
rest
watch out for the colors
send
[Music] [
Music] [
Music]
[Applause]
aerial of the Patrouille de France
made up of 8  Alpha Jet
and you are going to attend another
parade of a British A400M from the 30th
squadron of Rise Norton and the 4th is
130 from the 37th American air transport squadron
[Applause]
speech by Mr. Verrer Mayor of
Ver-sur-Mer
sir  the Minister for the Armed Forces
representing France
Mr. Minister of Defense of the
United Kingdom
Mr. Ambassador of Germany
Mrs. Minister representing
the Ambassador of Canada Mr.
Ambassador of Belgium
His Royal Highness Prince of Denmark
Mrs. Ambassador of  USA Mr.
Ambassador of Norway Mr.
Ambassador of the Netherlands Mr.
Ambassador of Poland Ladies and
gentlemen parliamentarians
Gentlemen Presidents of the
department region of the Community of Communes
gentlemen representatives of
defense and security authorities
gentlemen  veterans ladies and
gentlemen mothers and elected officials ladies
and gentlemen
I am particularly happy to
welcome you to the town of
Ver-sur-Mer and to this site of the
British Memorial I thank you for your
presence to commemorate together 79 years
after the landing  allied forces
on our beaches, some of whom have come from
far away to fight to liberate
Europe from fascism we do not forget
so our first thought goes to the
veterans we wish them great
recognition we are of course thinking of
all those who left their  life on
June 6 and in the war that followed we
think of all the military victims
we also think of all the
civilian victims and we thank the
British for having included on this site
a monument to the civilian victims
this site is exceptional it allows to
see the marsh the beach where the soldiers
landed the sea behind me which was
covered with boats and the pontoons
of Arromanches which are the remains of these
huge concrete caissons built in the
south of England and which have been
noticed from the sun  floating to
be filled with water here and form the breakwater
of the Mulberry be artificial harbor which
allowed the armies to land their
vehicle and their equipment you can
still see them this site was chosen by
the veterans themselves allow me
to  evoke in particular the memory of
George bats who left us recently
but who was able to come and visit this memorial
of which he was one of the initiators he
wanted to come to the town hall with his arms
full of testimonial gifts of
irreplaceable historical and sentimental value
if I was very moved by this meeting
what struck me was his great
emotion and the link he made
between the past and the present
today is the meaning of our
commemoration and we are there  bring
young people together, we also celebrate all those
involved in peace since this war,
and I have a special thought for those
involved in reconciliation between
France and Germany and those involved in
the construction of Europe
in this troubled world which  still knows
the war including at our gates
may we bring together the right
of peoples to dispose of the same and
democracy as an alternative to
violence as a factor of peace and
respect for freedoms thank you
Mr Jean Quétier president of the
landing committee
[  Applause]
[Music]
Ladies and gentlemen representatives
of Canada Germany Belgium Denmark Norway Netherlands Poland
United
States of
America United Kingdom
civil and military authority
welcome to this Ver Memorial site
-sur-Mer
on the evening of June 6,
132,000 soldiers had landed on our
shores,
including 73,000 British,
mainly at Gold Beach, an
immense effort and colossal sacrifice
to liberate the countries of Europe from a terrible ideology,
including the German people today
at our  sides to defend
freedom and democracy again
these values ​​must be the object of
all our attention
they are essential fragile but
never definitive
that is where everything is important I do
commemorations which do not content themselves with
evoking the past but which  we
also talk about our future
keep the memory of these women and
men who made this page
of history
as the general would be buried in
the cemetery of Ver-sur-Mer
resistant who participated in the
turtle plan to slow down the arrival of the
enemy tanks on Arromanches
arrest on June 14,
1944 tortured
then send to buckenval he approaches
General de Gaulle
examples like these are numerous let
's not forget those who gave us back
our freedom thank you
Mr. Martin Schaeffer
Plenipotent Minister of  Germany
Excellency
Ladies and gentlemen elected gentlemen
generals and admirals
dear friends soldiers soldiers and above all
charity
Lucas unfortunately cannot be
with us and attend this ceremony
today because he has just left
with the President of the Republic for the
meeting between the meaning of things and
President Macron this evening at pasta he
asked me to deliver on his behalf the speech
he had prepared
as German ambassador it is
a great donor for me to be able to
m  ssing you here today
as an official representative of Germany
speaking for the first time
during this
international ceremony on June 6 inspires me with a
deep sense of humility and
gratitude on June 6,
1944 and the end of  the Second
World War now belongs to
the distant past
and yet the terrible wounds
inflicted and the crimes committed in the name of
Germany have left traces even
after generations
history does not fade and nowhere neither
in Germany nor in  France
nor here the memory of the men of the women
and children murdered in the concentration camps of the
victims of Oradour-sur-Glane of the
resistance fighters and of the soldiers
who lost their lives in this conflict,
particularly here in Normandy, to remember
remains as  remains the pain of their
loved ones and family
us German together fully
aware for us June 6th is also
a day to remember the courage
of the Allied Amay forces who paved
the way for the end of World War II
to the liberation of  Paris and
France and the liberation of
Germany from Nazism on May 8,
in Berlin
barely 11 months later from June 6, 1944,
this day also represents an
opportunity to express our joy and our
gratitude for the reconciliation that
was possible after the atrocities of the
Second World War,
including between German and French,
given the bloody history of
our continent, this is like a
miracle a miracle that we owe to the
countless men and women who
contributed to overcoming  never the
European conflicts of the past
this day urges us to
commit ourselves with determination for peace
and freedom because it remains
threatened this is the reason why
Germany with its allies these allies
supports Ukraine on the
political levels  and economic
humanitarian and military also by
delivering weapons
with our collective support ukraine
must restore its sovereignty and
russian aggression must fail after
two global world wars
never again war has become the
lightning that has guided from germany
now it goes from  hand in hand with our
resolve to defend if necessary
every square inch of
NATO territory with our European and
North American allies today once
again our peace and freedom demands
courage
and  ready to defend them as a
whole it is also for us Germans
the heritage of June 6,
1944 I thank you
his excellent François de Kirch of
Belgium
Mr Minister of the Armed Forces
Ministry
Ladies and Gentlemen
Ambassadors Generals and Admirals
Mr Prefect
Mr. Chairman of the Landing Committee
Mr. Mayor of Ver-sur-Mer
Ladies and gentlemen elected officials of the
Republic in title and quality
today we are
traditionally gathered along these
beaches of Normandy where 79 years ago
thousands of young sailors
and airmen
it is with unequaled courage
launched in the liberation of Europe
often too often at the cost of their lives
this heroic attitude to which we
owe everything must never be forgotten
it must serve us as  examples to all
by showing us what generosity and
solidarity between the Allies should
be the most noble
[Applause]
from the Embassy of Canada
Mr. Minister of the
Landing Armies Mr. Mayor of
Ver-sur-Mer Ladies and Gentlemen  the elected
officials will all want some qualities
distinguish and avoid dear veterans dear
friends
what were the words of the Canadian soldier
what he felt in the early morning of
June 16, 1944 we landed right next
to here in the Dunod sector in
Courseulles-sur-  Sea loneliness in the face of
the immensity of its mission loneliness in the face
of dangers loneliness also in the face of
fate
all volunteers the more than 14,000
Canadian soldiers of the Allied landings
and the Battle of Normandy put
their courage at the service of the fight for
freedom  and democracy to liberate
the French cousins
from this Juno beach and the
kilometers of land that extends it
until when up to the cliff 5000 of
my compatriots lost their youth
and their lives some were not even
20 years old
they  it took immense courage
to fight continue to fight
when the fire broke out continue to
fight to protect yourself to protect your
loved ones and move forward even though your
loved ones were falling
fear we have it it's part of
everyday life the worst is  when it
was announced to me that I was losing friends
I had a lot of misery it's not
embarrassing a soldier he cries you know how to
testify another Canadian veteran I'm
soaked
it's to the conscience of these young people
of Canada and of  all the nations
years allied that of yesterday and
today to his courage his fear
his tears I want to pay tribute
today but it is also to that of
Ukraine for which a few kilometers
from here  the horrible history of the war
is repeated to this conscious and
responsible youth to this immensely courageous youth and milk
even if frightened to
this brave youth and comrades to
this fallen youth to
allow us to live in freedom to this
youth let us make this promise to
never forget we will remember
His Royal Highness General Prince
Joachim of Denmark Defense Attaché
of the Danish Embassy Your
Excellency
Ladies and Gentlemen,
Civil and Military Official Representatives, Ladies and
Gentlemen, Members of Parliament and
elected officials,
Ladies and Gentlemen, Veterans
It is with humility that  I
speak as
Denmark's Defense Attaché in France here in the
windy fields of Normandy on
such an important date as June 6, right here
where soldiers from great nations
disembarked from their ships to fight the
battle that changed  fate
WWII
a battle for the freedom of Europe
demanding immense sacrifice
even though on April 9, 1940 Denmark
was invaded occupied by
Nazi Germany this did not stop the Danes from
carrying out the good  fight elsewhere
at the time 245 merchant ships and 6300
sailors sailed the
international waters where the quays were located
abroad
they were suddenly cut off from their
homeland
instead of waiting in horror and
despair for the vast majority of these
ships  and their crews chose to
serve the allies
during the war 50,000 Danes were
involved in the
resistance movements against the Nazi occupiers
on June 6, 1944 around thirty ships
and more than 800 Danish sailors
took part in landing operations
on the  same beaches where we are
gathered today
airmen of a black also
took part in the air attacks and
danish soldiers took part in
commando operations behind enemy lines
among the annois who served with the
allies during the second
world war  one in 6 sailors and one
in 10 soldiers and airmen lost their lives
today
we are not content to just
commemorate my fellow citizens who have so
bravely joined the allies' just fight
and so we will not
just be honoring those  who served
and paid the ultimate price for our
freedom
we also remember why they
did it because
Europe's peace and freedom have been
threatened again for almost a year and a half
Ukraine has been showing a  incredible
bravery in resisting the terrible and
inexcusable russian invasion
jesus feared fight for the
freedom we hold so dear their
fight is a painful reminder
that we can never take
our freedom for granted and that every
man or woman who fights or  are
beaten for her deserve our respect
our support and our commemoration
[Music]
her excellence of risk
ambassador of the United States
her Excellency
ambassador of Norway
Ladies and gentlemen dear friends I am
honored to be able to commemorate with you
this 79th anniversary of the
allied landings today  today France
Great Britain Norway and all our
allies remember with emotion
attached 1944 when the Allies
landed in force and by surprise
on its Normandy beaches we will
remember with gratitude all those
who fought for freedom  and
democracy
This British Memory Number An
extraordinary monument is a permanent reminder
of the bonds that united the allies in the
battle against Nazi Germany
during World War II and of
those who all sacrificed
This ceremony reminds us that
peace and  freedom does not come without
effort and it summons the memory of those
who have all sacrificed for our freedom
all those who have sacrificed their presence
so that the following generations is
a future
today with the invasion of Ukraine
by Russia  Europe's security
is again threatened and staying in
solidarity with each other
seems more important than ever with
time with Germany we are
united and our unity is even enlarged
with the welcome of Finland and soon
joined by Sweden which will
strengthen cooperation and security
in the alliance it reminds us of our
common struggles and the importance of
solidarity in the face of threats that we
cannot defeat alone we must
remain in a brotherhood of nations
that share  the same ideas this
fraternity which is at the heart of our
democracies and which remains
as vital as ever today
there are not many witnesses left
for February these memories and golden yellows
the veterans here present
today
and this justifies all the more  more this
ceremony and commemoration especially in
the troubled times we are living
today we are together and
guardians of the memory thank you
his Excellency signature ambassador of the
Netherlands
minister
ladies and gentlemen
civil and military authorities
ladies and gentlemen it is  an honor
to address you here to do at sea
to commemorate June 6 here on the
beaches of Normandy where the
Allied forces landed during the Second
World War thanks to these joint efforts
Europe was able to be freed from
dictatorship  nazi it is also thanks to its
common efforts that we are still
free in 203
it touches me to be able to take part in
this commemoration in normandy
especially since the witnesses of this
terrible war are less and less
numerous our mission is to  to defend
peace and freedom and to continue to
transmit the importance and the value of
this so that the little children
even if their grandparents were born
after 1945
can feel the weight of this
responsibility
so that history continues to  be
transmitted
and it is for the end of the year
especially when the horrors of war
are still family every day
dozens of soldiers die on the front
in Ukraine
the Netherlands supports the
Ukrainian government in its heroic resistance to
the Russian invasion  their freedom is
our freedom regale here on the beaches
of Normandy in 1944
[Applause]
[Music]
of Poland
[Applause]
of the Battle of Normandy and Monsieur
Benoît
[Applause] [
Music] [
Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
by Mr. Sébastien Lecornu Minister
of the Armed Forces
[Music]
Your Excellency Mr. Secretary
of State for Defense of the Kingdom of
Great Britain
Ladies and Gentlemen Ambassadors
Ladies and Gentlemen Members of Parliament
Mr. Prefect Mr. Mayor
Ladies  and gentlemen elected
general officers officers
non-commissioned officers petty officers
soldiers sailors and French
and allied airmen
Ladies and gentlemen veterans and
former combatants ladies and
gentlemen
79 years ago exactly on the morning
of a new day which saw
hope reborn  these beaches welcome in the
din of arms the return of freedom
to our continent
that morning all the sand and all the
Cumes of these beaches which extend from
Ouistreham to Saint-Martin de variville
were reddened by the blood of 3000 young people
American men British Canadians
but also French with the 177 sailors from
the commando which delivered
a few kilometers of Normandy coast
for the arrival of a million
American reinforcements British Canadian Dutch
Greek Belgian Polish Norwegian
Danish and many others
volunteering with  of the allied forces
that morning at the beginning of what
was going to be the longest day the
bombs of the allied aviation soon
joined by those of the ships of
operation Neptune where 133,000 soldiers were piled up with
beating hearts and
hands  sweaty imagining the fate that
awaited them they were going to join
this mother of fire and blood who
will seal the course of their life and that
of our destiny
soon he engages in the
icy blades of the Channel buried or
kilos of ammunition and not  more bullets
than the enemy lurking in the shadow of these
concrete loopholes never delivered to their
young chests a generation of
soldiers
than that morning to deliver a few
kilometers of coastline and warn of the fate
that the Allies reserved for war at
Europe and the world victory and liberation
that morning was for them the supreme dawn
it remains so 79 years later for us
who still owe them to live free
and in peace
on this beach of Gold Beach from 5:30 am
the first  bombers attack the
enemy positions at the same time the
first British infantrymen placed
under the orders of lieutenant general
bucknal embark in their landing craft
they melt in a rough sea and
accompanied by the amphibious cats of the
Black Dragons the drownings are numerous
on the beach it is necessary  cover and crawl
then get up and go again allowing
a tank to open a passage in the middle of the morning
in which the
British soldiers will rush before attacking
the German positions which will
all be neutralized here with
the Stevens green Howards commanded by
sergeant holist  attacks the
enemy artillery battery and takes 30
prisoners this feat of arms will earn him
the Victoria Cross and the glory that
history reserves for the hero through this
memorial located at the exact location of
his exploit
on the evening of June 6  British
landed more than 22 men on Gold
Beach and controlled an area of ​​10 km².
the advanced elements of the 50th division
arrived at the gates of Bayeux on
the left flank the junction was made
with the Canadians landed them on
Juno Beach for the inhabitants of the
commune who discovered these thousands John
soldier landed in the night from their
neighboring island  their words in English which
then resounded in the streets of the
city had that day the language of
freedom found
from this memorial where
the names of the 22,442 soldiers of
the British army landed on its
beaches are inscribed in stone.  we of their courage and
what we owe them
listen to the survivors who
accompany us today and do not forget
their words those who saw their
comrades fall on its beaches they
know better than anyone else the price
of our freedom
let us remember  tell us of the solidarity of our
allies the efforts of their people
who behind their borders have
consented to the pact of blood labor
tears and sweat to never
give up the fight that led us
together to victory
that morning  a new fight has
opened led in the shadows by
thousands of French people
forming an army of shadows
commanded from London by General
de Gaulle and mobilized in every
village on every road at every
railroad interchange to corner
the enemy and accelerate the  advance of the
Allies when these French did not
liberate themselves they too paid
with their courage and very often with their
lives our freedom was taken away
that morning
at last a beam of light in the
immense and black night  millions of
victims of nazism deported by
whole train to the east to be cowardly
finished there let's never forget them that
morning 3000 young soldiers fell
so that three generations of women and
men live free and happy after
them let's never forget  never what we
owe them and what it would cost us to
give up what they bequeathed to us so as
not to wake up one morning under a
sky of fire long live our allies long live
Franco-British friendship long live the
republic and long live  France
[Applause]
rest
the British veterans and the
authorities will advance towards the
monument for the wreath laying
will follow the ringing of the dead a
minute of silence and the
British and French national anthems
[Music]
[Applause]
when  Morocco Day
Mr. Sébastien Lecornu Minister of the
Armies
to the Dead
[Music] [
Music] to
rest
the authorities will now salute the
flag bearers of the patriotic associations
watch out
[Music]
present
hello everyone hello hello
everything is fine hello
[  Music]
thank you for your presence in any case
[Music]
bank
precisely it is with you that I in front of it
[Music]
very soon
hello that goes
in any case thank you to the citizen reserve please
you are well that  okay
thank you very much hello you are fine see you
soon
[Music]
exactly
[Music] thank you
in any case thank you we
have this Merit Calvados
[Music]
perfect hello you are fine
throughout France for tomorrow thank you
anyway thank you very much how
are you okay
[Music]
we like
three beers to get
into the
[Music]
thank you [
Music]
that I met
[Music]
marine see you later Hubert Joseph
thank you anyway
[  Music]
thank you anyway thank you very much you
're fine
but why not thank you for
[Music]
the awesomeplanet
of fighters
I think it's Friday night
today
[Music]
by an honor platoon of sailors from
the garrison of  Cherbourg by a
detachment of students from the military school
of Autun by a detachment from the
territorial station of Denmark
in the presence of the flag of the
air base 105 of Évreux and its guard in the
company of the band of the Army
of  Air and Space
[Music]
rest
a rest
the troop commander will now
render the honors to the flag of
airbase 105
attention
[Music]
present
to the flag
[Music]
good is everyone ready
hello to all thank you to
the press for covering all of this
important day which at the bottom of the
several moments obviously a moment
linked to our French armed forces
this morning with obviously the
traditional ceremony of handing over the
green berets to our commands  marines
that the President of the Republic held
to himself chaired which also enabled me
to present a certain number
of decorations to soldiers of our
special forces engaged in
delicate and difficult missions
in particular in connection with the fight against
terrorism  this afternoon obviously
with these international ceremonies on
which is Ben Wallace and the eye of
Sting decided to respond
favorably to the invitation with a
particularity on the
Franco-British friendship here therefore for this
memorial which had been inaugurated by
Theresa  May and Emmanuel Macron a
few years ago
and on which we wanted to hold
the international ceremony and which
allowed us to pay tribute and
obviously listen to our veterans does
not hide from you that these ceremonies are
special for the
French government for  state services
for the armed forces since it is
also the preparation of the ceremonies for
next year's
90th anniversary which is a moment which
is going to be humanly and particularly
dense and perhaps also difficult because
our veterans are
gradually going away little by little so
obviously the duty of memory becomes
even more imperative and more than
necessary and then in a very
symbolic way but it is not
anecdotal in the sub-prefecture of
Bayeux at the beginning  afternoon we
held a P3, that is to say a
Minister of Defense format United States
of America Kingdom of Great Britain and
France on topical subjects
which I could come back to in a
moment  but it's been a long time since a P3
Minister of Defense had been
organized,
we proposed it to our American colleague
three or four months ago now, he responded
favorably to the organization of this
meeting which is  important because
our three countries obviously have specific responsibilities
particularly in the
United Nations Security Council particular because
we are the three
nuclear powers of NATO particular because
we are three democracies
obviously committed to a system of
values ​​which, moreover,  has largely taken
its roots and its legitimacy on these
beaches and therefore we took the opportunity
to sweep a certain number of
current topics obviously the
Ukrainian counter-offensive currently underway the
situation obviously in terms of
military aid in particular not only but
finally essentially military aid
for the Ministers of Defense for
Ukraine in this important period
the Venus summit since a
NATO summit will be held in the month of July and
we have obviously programmed it plus
security subjects more  issues
such as
nuclear proliferation or the
fight against terrorism in Africa,
which obviously remains a subject of
major concern, so it is
both a day of memory of the tradition
of respect for the word also of our
elders at this  moment was very moving a
few moments ago we could
hear this British veteran it is
also a moment for us
French authorities of preparation for the
ceremonies of next year which in
addition I remind you will request
the services of the  State and for good
reason because there is also
the organization of the Olympic Games so
it will be a particularly dense
and rich summer for our country and then
also of course current topics
which relate to overall security at the
security of Europe or the
Atlantic Alliance, which led us to have
this rather historic meeting in the
sub-prefecture of Bayeux, which is a
sub-prefecture that has experienced some in
terms of history, but this afternoon
modestly we are  also came to
bring this stone here I am
not longer and I will perhaps
leave my friend Ben whom I thank for
his presence I would like to publicly
thank all the same for his francophilia
he understands French himself he
spent a lot of  time in France and
since my appointment
more than a year ago as Minister of the Armies
Ben Wallace has proven to be a
reliable committed partner we held a
summit as you know with
Prime Minister Sunac and President
Macron he  it has now been three months over
which we have been able to make
major commitments, we have very
regular rhythms and I would also like to say this
publicly if anyone is worried that
brexit could have had an effect on the
security relationship between London  and
Paris it is not so and I think
it is also due to the relationship that we
have both managed to establish as well as
the relationship that our armed forces
maintain on a daily basis so thanks to
oscata was to British Defense
for being  present for his ceremonies since
yesterday evening where we can
tell you now we even
escaped this night to go to the foot
of the Pegasus Bridge and we also
went to see Arlette for the
champagne ceremony which allowed us
to  give a few
cold surfs to our safety and to the
prefecture of Calvados but it
also shows what we wanted to do
for these commemorations
[Music]
the dam that was destroyed this morning
all the evidence there is
significant land activity  which has been observed
in recent times in recent days I
believe that there is no mystery that the
Ukrainian authorities obviously
qualify things afterwards, as we
all know, there are obviously
significant capacities that Ukraine is in the process
of reconstituting to reconstitute  for
many weeks now,
many months also for this reason that
France or Great Britain have
accompanied with training with
obviously a lot of equipment,
in particular on solar defense on
deep strikes on
obviously equipment in
land matters for  reconstitute
brigade units, including even at the
divisional level and so we can clearly see that there
is an activity I don't know if we can
say that it's time for the
counter-defensive way it doesn't belong
to me French Minister of Defense  to
say it in any case there is a
terrestrial activity of all the obviousnesses which
resumes more beautiful and which testify
in any case to an intensity of the conflicts
which are repeated if it is a certainty
the same thing as well here I think  that
on the various major
highlights that we can analyze or
look at I think it is good that the
various ministers do not
comment too much on them there are
discussions taking place with the
various intelligence services
military, including in connection
with the Ukrainian partner, of course,
we talked about it earlier with the
American authorities and the
British authorities, but once again I think
that it is not for me to make
superfluous comments to destroy
civil infrastructures endangering
populations, nature and perhaps even
other elements of security and
stability in a region it's called
a war crime but it's not the
first war crime that we
would unfortunately encounter in Ukraine
since the beginning of this
British conflict on the part of the government
that the project was winged it was
rusting a step
for
the better and it is often in the
comments
the relations between the communes the State
and the embassy are
excellent relations and that  in just a few
years there has been a
major renovation program of many
monuments on the whole not only
of the coast but also of the interior of the
lands for once there are and
major efforts that are made and
things  moving in the right direction we
will continue to do so and understood with
our American Canadian friends
the place has not yet been revealed and the
discussions continue France
organizes and we obviously do it in
very close connection with the various
with the various allied countries and  for
once we have the President of the
Republic announced it just now we have
a public interest group which has just
been set up with a
general officer of the army that I have that
I have  appointed with an ambassador who will
begin to bring forward
proposals in a
very partnership-based manner with the various
allies, as each of the ceremonies is
particularly the ceremonies in 10,
as we say so well, quite
simply because I spent 15
days  in the National Assembly on the
debate for the military programming law
and that I had the opportunity to
talk a lot about the skull and that I am
also Minister of Ancient compactors
and memory I am not a
communist of the armies and that  it was
important for me to preside over this
ceremony alongside Ben Wallace
to set aside speaking time in front of
our veterans for these
memorial questions, I do them for
our allies, I also wanted to talk about
such internal resistance because  I
think it's an equally what
happens what happens from June 6th
from the Day also takes us to the
many liberation ceremonies that
sometimes take place very late at the end of
August beginning of  month of September
because there were many pockets of resistance
so there I
really wanted to have a word that was also
linked to our history because if we go
too fast we end up not dealing with
things properly after I told you
said today we also made this
choice not to do only the Memorial
that's why we isolated ourselves for
almost an hour and a half at the
sub-prefecture of Bayeux to deal with
the various current topics
frankly he explained to us why
France seems reluctant to open
a NATO office in Japan
it's not so much that we are reluctant it's
that we are asking to have a
global reflection on obviously  this question
since the presence of an office of
the North Atlantic Alliance in a
Pacific Ocean seems to me to be a sufficiently
legitimate question for us to be
able to ask it here I am, like a
former Minister of Overseas, a good
connoisseur I believe
Indo-Pacific issues and I think it is indeed
good that the Atlantic lance
also concentrates on missions which
are those of reassurance at the moment,
for example on the eastern flank of
Europe on security missions at
sea  in the Mediterranean Sea in the Atlantic
I think that the subjects are not lacking
my will have the opportunity to come back to it in Vilnus
during the NATO summit and even before
the ministerial which will take place in
June in Brussels